[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video were going to be dressing a
question that many fans have likely
asked themselves and that is why on
earth did Harry just drop the
resurrection stone in the Forbidden
Forest after he had possession of it why
didn't he hold on to it for longer the
resurrection stone is of course one of
the fabled Deathly Hallows stemming from
the tale of the three brothers
Antioch Cadmus ending notice the
brothers were all members of the famous
Peveril family the plot surrounds the
three West's brothers and their ability
to cheat death for a short period of
time after conquering death a
personification of death under the guise
of congratulating them awarded them with
three gifts the Elder Wand the
resurrection stone and the invisibility
cloak long story short each brother
chose one of the gifts the death had
presented them big notice the youngest
chose the invisibility cloak Cadmus the
middle brother chose a resurrection
stone and Antioch the eldest chose the
Elder Wand he is an excerpt from the
tale of the three brothers then the
second brother who was an arrogant man
decided that he wanted to humiliate
death still further and asked for the
power to recall others from death so
death picked up a stone from the
riverbank and gave it to the second
brother and told him that the stone
would have the power to bring back the
dead it is actually been expressed that
Cadmus is a direct descendant of the
gaunt family as they held the stone in
their family for years after his demise
there are many unknown owners of the
stone including death who manufactured
it
Cadmus Peverill generations of unknown
haunts often Marvolo Tom Riddle and many
more and eventually the stone was in
Harry Potter's possession and it is
Harry Potter who we see let it slip from
his fingers in the following passage
from chapter 34 of the Deathly Hallows I
thought he would come said Voldemort in
his high clear voice his eyes and the
leaf in flames
I expected him to come nobody spoke they
seemed as scared as Harry whose heart is
now throwing itself against his ribs as
though determined to escape the body he
was about to cast aside his hands were
sweating as he pulled off the
invisibility cloak and stuffed it
beneath his robes with his wand he did
not want to be tempted to fight I was it
seems mistaken said Voldemort
you weren't Harry said it as loudly as
he could with all the force he could
muster he did not want to sound afraid
the resurrection stone stepped from
between his numbed fingers and out of
the corner of his eye he saw his parents
Sirius and Lupin vanish as he stepped
forward into the firelight at that
moment he felt that nobody mattered but
Voldemort it was just the two of them so
you may ask why would Harry simply drop
an artifact created by Death himself the
stone after all is said to be the only
object that would bring back the spirits
of the holders deceased loved ones
activating when turned three times in
the user's hand seems like a lot of
power Harry of course uses it to summon
the images of his loved ones
and while the stone was initially
thought to bring back the dead in
totality in reality it only brings back
a shade of these people it is been
expressed that the shades produced are
less substantial than living bodies but
much more than ghosts and Harry even
went on to describe them as transparent
producing a Patronus like effect that
helps shield him against Dementors
essentially the stones inability to
properly cheat death was just way of
punishing the arrogant Peveril brother
it just gave people a sample of what it
would be like to be reunited with these
people and in Katniss's case he killed
himself to properly be with the girl
that he loved once more
Harry doesn't have any interest in
keeping the stone for a number of
reasons the first reason being that
Harry never had any intention or
ambition becoming the master of death
one who possesses all three Hallows the
resurrection stone invisibility cloak an
Elder Wand is thought to hold this title
but only if they are able to accept the
death is inevitable Dumbledore was very
explicit with Harry
when he explained that Voldemort's fear
of death an attempted mastery over it
was the primary root of all of his evil
and Harry wanted no part of that at all
Harry just wanted to live a peaceful
normal life with his loved ones and had
no grand aspirations of cheating death
or becoming immortal
additionally Harry was simply done with
the stone he'd gotten the use out of it
that he required and did not need it
anymore it served no purpose to him as a
hallow and he likely felt that as just
another Rock on the forest floor it
probably wasn't a threat to anyone in
the following excerpt Harry confirmed
with Dumbledore that he left the stone
in the forest and has no interest in
returning for it the thing that was
hidden in the snitch he began I dropped
it in the forest I don't know exactly
where but I'm not going to go looking
for it again
do you agree my dear boy I do said
Dumbledore while his fellow pictures
looked confused and curious a wise and
courageous decision but no less than I
would have expected of you does anybody
else know where it fell no one said
Harry and Dumbledore nodded his
satisfaction
JK Rowling would Lisa add when asked
about whether or not the stone would
ever be found I think not I imagined
that it was squashed into the ground by
a centaurs hoof as the centrioles dash
to the aid of the Hogwarts fighters and
thereafter became buried and that's it
for this video I hope that helps to
address the question of why Harry would
just drop the stone if you enjoyed the
content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
you're a wizard Harry
[Music]
you